the attacks come with terrifying
regularity here in the world's largest
mangrove swamp in the Bay of Bengal
villagers trudged through a murky River
to net shrimp larvae locals speak of a
monster that attacks underwater without
warning it happened to Sumitra mystery
Peggy salam para dar bikini bodies
elephant alone in cabo da da it was an
ordinary day I woke up and then i went
for fishing in the river i was pulling
my net in the water for 3 hours when the
animal bit me it was like a sharp razor
cut I pushed the animal and it
immediately took off my hand I swam to
the shore and saw the blood running from
my hand
many here bear the scars of these
frightening encounters National
Geographic biologist rocky strong and
adventurer Fabien Cousteau have come to
investigate rocky believes the culprit
might be a bull shark let's go
they set the bait
why this spot versus any other this is a
place where two major rivers converge
and even more importantly all the locals
say this is a good spot for sharks
Oh something is biting
but the researchers can't make a catch
well no no really even good good bites I
have to say it's the longest time I've
spent fishing without any results at all
later they're led to a market with two
small sharks are for sale so in here all
yours I'm rapid goodness gracious ah
this is this is a brand new pup by the
look of the umbilical marks these pups
were newborns male and the female to
determine the species the researchers
count t 1 2 5 6 7 8 9 and 10 that's our
fish it's conclusive these are bull
sharks as rocky suspected this sometimes
aggressive species has been documented
in rivers throughout the world
rocky's theory is that bull sharks
develop the ability to live temporarily
in fresh water so that females can give
birth where their young are safest from
other sharks but maybe it's after giving
birth that the females had further up
river in search of food sometimes
encountering people y of a river versus
say further down the coast or deeper
into the ocean because they can because
they can leave all their competitors
behind and be king of the hill up inside
a an environment that they're very good
at dealing with and other sharks just
aren't
both shark and human are seeking food in
these waters to help them survive
and that competition can sometimes lead
to dangerous clashes